El MIT
averiguó una cosa
hace un par de años. Ken Hale,
que es lingüista,
dijo que de las 6.000 lenguas
que se hablan ahora mismo en la Tierra,
3.000 no las hablan los niños.
De modo que dentro de una generación,
veremos reducida nuestra diversidad cultural a la mitad.
Continuó diciendo
que cada dos semanas
un anciano se va a la tumba
llevándose la última palabra hablada
de esa cultura.
De modo que toda una filosofía,
un conjunto de conocimientos sobre el mundo natural
recogido empíricamente a lo largo de siglos,
desaparece.
Y esto ocurre cada dos semanas.
Así que durante los últimos 20 años,
desde mi última intervención dental,
he estado viajando por el mundo
y volviendo
con historias sobre algunos de esos pueblos.
Y... lo que me gustaría hacer ahora
es compartir algunas de esas historias con vosotros.
Ésta es Tamdin.
Es una monja de 69 años.
La metieron en la cárcel en Tibet durante dos años
por colocar una diminuta pancarta
en protesta por la ocupación de su país.
Cuando la conocí, acababa de
atravesar el Himalaya,
desde Lhasa, la capital de Tibet,
hasta Nepal, atravesando la India...
30 días...
para conocer a su líder, el Dalai Lama.
El Dalai Lama vive en Dharamsala, India.
Saqué esta fotografía tres días
después de que llegara,
y llevaba puesto un par de zapatillas destrozadas,
con los dedos asomando por delante.
Y cruzó en marzo,
hay mucha nieve a 5.600 metros en marzo.
Éste es Paldin.
Paldin es un monje de 62 años.
Pasó 33 años en la cárcel.
A todo su monasterio les metieron en la cárcel
en la época de las revueltas,
cuando el Dalai Lama tuvo que abandonar
Tibet.
Y
le golpearon, le privaron de comida,
le torturaron... perdió todos los dientes en prisión.
Cuando yo le conocí, era un viejito amable y dulce.
Esto me impresionó mucho...
-le conocí dos semanas después de salir de la cárcel-
que pasara por esa experiencia y acabara
con el comportamiento que tenía.
Así que estuve en Dharamsala conociendo a esa gente,
pasé unas cinco semanas allí,
estuve escuchando historias parecidas
de los refugiados que habían salido de Tibet
para llegar a Dharamsala.
Y coincidió que, la quinta semana,
se celebró una enseñanza pública del Dalai Lama.
Y
yo observaba a la multitud de monjes y monjas,
muchos de los cuales acababa de entrevistar,
y de escuchar sus historias,
y observé sus caras.
Nos dieron una pequeña radio FM
para que pudiéramos escuchar la traducción de sus enseñanzas.
Y lo que dijo fue:
"trata a tus enemigos como si fueran joyas preciosas,
porque son tus enemigos
los que forjan tu tolerancia y paciencia
en el camino hacia la iluminación".
Yo no pude... eso me impactó muchísimo,
que le dijera eso a una gente que había pasado por tanto.
Así que dos meses después fui al
Tibet y empecé a
entrevistar a gente allí, a tomar fotografías. Eso es lo que hago,
entrevisto y hago retratos.
Y ésta es una niñita,
a la que le saqué una foto subida en lo más alto del Templo Jokhang.
Yo había metido a escondidas...
porque es totalmente ilegal tener fotos del Dalai Lama en Tibet,
es la forma más rápida de que te detengan.
Pero había metido un puñado de fotos pequeñas del Dalai Lama,
y las estuve repartiendo.
Cuando se las daba a la gente,
o las sostenían contra el pecho,
o las sostenían contra la frente y las dejaban ahí.
Y eso es...
bueno, en aquel momento, eso fue hace 10 años,
36 años después de que el Dalai Lama se hubiera ido.
Así que
fui y estuve entrevistando a la gente y haciéndoles fotografías.
Éstas son Jigme y su hermana, Sonam.
Viven en Chang Tang, en la Meseta Tibetana,
en la parte más occidental del país.
Eso está a casi 5.200 metros.
Y acababan de bajar de los pastos de altura,
a 5.500 metros.
Y lo mismo, le dí una foto,
y la sujetó contra su frente.
Normalmente reparto Polaroids
cuando hago esto, porque coloco luces,
y compruebo mis luces,
y cuando le enseñé una Polaroid, gritó y corrió a su tienda.
Éste es Tenzin Gyatso,
a los dos años se descubrió que era el Buda de la Compasión,
en la casa de un campesino,
en medio de la nada.
A los cuatro años fue instaurado
como el 14º Dalai Lama.
En la adolescencia se enfrentó
a la invasión de su país,
y tuvo que resolverlo, era el líder de su país.
Ocho años después, cuando descubrieron que se tramaba
su asesinato,
le vistieron como un mendigo
y le sacaron a escondidas a caballo del país,
haciendo el mismo viaje que hizo Tamdin.
Y ahora vive... nunca ha vuelto a su país desde entonces.
Y
si piensan en ese hombre,
46 años más tarde,
aún se aferra
a su respuesta de no violencia
ante un problema político y de derechos humanos muy serio.
Y la gente joven,
los tibetanos jóvenes, están empezando a decir: "oye, no funciona".
O sea, la violencia como herramienta política
es la última moda ahora mismo.
Y
él sigue aferrándose a su postura.
Así que éste es el icono
de la no violencia en nuestro mundo...
uno de nuestros iconos vivos.
Éste es otro líder de su pueblo.
Es Moi y esto es en el Amazonas ecuatoriano.
Moi tiene 35 años.
Y
en esta zona del Amazonas ecuatoriano
se descubrió petróleo en 1972.
En este período de tiempo, desde entonces,
la misma cantidad de petróleo, o el doble,
de lo que se vertió en el accidente del Exxon Valdez,
se ha vertido en esta pequeña zona del Amazonas,
y las tribus de esa zona han tenido que mudarse constantemente.
Moi
pertenece a la tribu huaorani,
se dice que son
muy feroces, y se los conoce como "auca".
Ellos han conseguido mantener a raya
a sismólogos y empleados petroleros
con lanzas y cerbatanas.
Yo pasé...
bueno, pasamos, fui con un equipo,
dos semanas con estos tipos en la selva,
viendo cómo cazaban.
Esto fue en una cacería de monos,
cazando con dardos envenenados con curare.
El conocimiento que esta gente tiene
de su entorno natural es increíble.
Pueden oír cosas, oler cosas y ver cosas que yo no puedo ver.
Yo no podía siquiera ver los monos
que ellos estaban
cazando con sus dardos.
Ésta es Yadira.
Yadira tiene
cinco años. Ella pertenece a una
tribu vecina de los huaorani.
Su tribu ha tenido que mudarse
tres veces en los últimos 10 años por culpa de los derrames de petróleo.
Nosotros nunca hemos oído hablar de eso. El último
delito contra estos pueblos es que,
como parte del Plan Colombia,
estamos rociando con Paraquat o Roundup, o lo que sea,
estamos defoliando miles de hectáreas
de Amazonas ecuatoriano
en nuestra lucha contra la droga.
Y estos pueblos son los más castigados por ello.
Éste es Mengatoue.
Es el chamán de los huaorani,
y él...
bueno, nos dijo: "bueno, yo ya soy viejo,
ya estoy cansado, ¿sabes? Estoy cansado
de alejar a esos explotadores petroleros,
ojalá se marchasen".
Normalmente viajo solo
cuando trabajo, pero esto lo hice
- conduje un programa para Discovey -
y cuando fui con el equipo
me preocupaba bastante
ir con todo un grupo de gente, sobre todo por los huaorani,
por meternos en su tribu.
Y
resultó que esos chicos me enseñaron
bien un par de cosas sobre cómo mezclarte
con los lugareños.
(Risas)
Una de las cosas que hice
justo antes del 11-S,
en agosto de 2001,
fue llevar a mi hijo Dax,
que tenía 16 años entonces,
a Paquistán.
Porque al principio quería,
bueno, ya le había llevado de viaje un par de veces,
pero quería que viera a
gente que vive con un dólar al día o menos.
Quería que viviera una experiencia
en el mundo islámico
y también quería que...
-iba a ir allí a trabajar con un grupo,
para hacer una historia sobre un grupo llamado los kalash,
que son un grupo de animus, 3.000 animus,
que viven en una zona muy pequeña
rodeados por el Islam; y sólo quedan 3.000
kalash. Un pueblo increíble.-
Así que era una gran experiencia para él. Estuvo toda la noche despierto con ellos,
tocando el tambor y bailando.
Él se llevó una pelota de fútbol,
y jugamos al fútbol todas las noches en ese pueblito.
Luego fuimos a
conocer a su chamán.
Por cierto, Mengatoue también era el
chamán de su tribu.
Y éste es John Doolikahn,
que es el chamán de los kalash.
Vive arriba, en las montañas,
justo en la frontera con Afganistán.
De hecho, al otro lado hay una zona, Tora Bora,
que es donde
se supone que está Osama bin Laden. Ésta es la zona tribal.
Nosotros vimos
y estuvimos con
John Doolikahn.
El chamán... yo he hecho toda una serie sobre el chamanismo,
que es un
fenómeno interesante.
Pero en distintas partes del mundo
entran en trance de formas distintas,
y en Paquistán
ellos lo hacen quemando hojas de enebro
y sacrificando a un animal;
vierten la sangre del animal sobre las hojas
y luego inhalan el humo.
Todos rezan
a los dioses de la montaña mientras
entran en trance.
Eso fue... bueno,
hacer que los chicos se acostumbren a realidades distintas,
creo que es muy importante. Lo que Dan Dennett dijo el otro día,
que tener un plan de estudios en el que vean distintas religiones
para que tengan más flexibilidad mental,
les da flexibilidad mental
acerca de sistemas de creencias distintos.
Creo que eso es muy necesario hoy en día
ya que vemos cómo chocan las creencias
y los problemas de seguridad que provocan.
Así que hace cinco años
iniciamos un programa que enlaza a niños
de comunidades indígenas con niños estadounidenses.
Primero conectamos a un
grupo del Pueblo Navajo con una clase de Seattle.
Ahora tenemos 15 sitios web.
Tenemos uno en Katmandú, Nepal;
en Dharamsala, India; en Takaungu, Kenia...
Takaungu es un tercio cristiano, un tercio musulmán
y un tercio animus, es decir, la comunidad.
En Ollantaytambo, Perú;
y en Arctic Village, Alaska.
Éste es Daniel, es uno de nuestros estudiantes
de Arctic Village, Alaska.
Vive en una cabaña de troncos,
sin agua corriente, sin más calefacción que...
sin ventanas
ni conexión rápida a Internet.
Y esto es... esto es...
veo que se estira por todas partes...
éste es nuestro sitio de Ollantaytambo, Perú, hace cuatro años,
cuando vieron sus primeros ordenadores.
Ahora tienen ordenadores en las clases.
Y lo que hacemos es...
enseñamos a estos niños a contar historias digitalmente.
Hacemos que nos cuenten historias sobre los problemas de su comunidad
que a ellos les importan.
Y esto es en Perú, donde los niños contaron una historia
sobre un río que ellos limpiaron.
Y todo esto lo hacemos en talleres.
Traemos a gente que quiere aprender
a contar historias y a trabajar digitalmente
y hacemos que
trabajen con los niños.
Y justo el año pasado hemos llevado a un grupo de adolescentes
y ha funcionado a la perfección.
Nuestro sueño es reunir a adolescentes
para que vivan la experiencia de un servicio comunitario,
además de una experiencia intercultural,
mientras enseñan a niños de esas zonas
y les ayudan a construir una infraestructura de comunicaciones.
Esto es una clase de Photoshop
en el pueblo de niños tibetanos de Dharamsala.
Tenemos un sitio web donde los niños ponen su página propia.
Estos son todos sus vídeos. Tenemos unos 60 vídeos
que han hecho estos chicos,
y son bastante impresionantes.
Ahora quiero enseñaros...
Después de que hagan los vídeos,
reservamos una noche para que se los enseñen a la comunidad.
Esto es en Takaungu,
donde tenemos un generador y un proyector digital
y proyectamos contra la pared de un granero,
y pasamos uno de los vídeos que han hecho.
Y si tenéis la oportunidad, podéis ir a nuestra web, y veréis
el trabajo increíble que hacen estos niños.
Los niños de nuestro... eso es lo otro,
quería dar voz a los pueblos indígenas.
Ésa fue una de las motivaciones principales.
Pero el otro motivo fundamental es
la naturaleza insular de nuestro país.
National Geographic acaba de publicar el Estudio Roper
a chicos de entre 18 y 26 años
de nuestro país
y otros nueve países industrializados.
Un estudio que ha costado dos millones de dólares.
Estados Unidos estaba penúltimo
en conocimientos geográficos.
El 70% de los chicos no supo localizar
Afganistán o Irak en un mapa.
El 60% no supo encontrar la India;
el 30% no sabía dónde estaba el Océano Pacífico.
Y éste es un estudio
que se realizó apenas hace un par de años.
Así que me gustaría enseñaros,
en el par de minutos que me quedan,
un vídeo de un estudiante de Guatemala.
Acabábamos de celebrar un taller en Guatemala.
Una semana antes del taller,
un enorme desprendimiento de tierra provocado por el huracán Stan
de octubre pasado, había enterrado
vivas a 600 personas en su pueblo.
Este niño vivía en el pueblo,
pero no estaba allí en ese momento,
y éste es el vídeo que hizo sobre el tema.
Y antes de hacer este vídeo, nunca antes había
visto un ordenador. Le enseñamos a manejar Photoshop y...
sí, podemos ponerlo.
Eso es un antiguo canto funerario maya
que aprendió de su abuelo.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplauso)